but when you guys got the news that  katie was joining the warriors what was  that group chat like with the  [Music]  that's how i was bro just like because  you know you're gonna have to see them  in the finals i'm like for what that's  what uh that's all we all looking like  huh then we like well russ got to say  about that's what we all want russ for  to say about this [ __ ] this is crazy  um  but you know as well  that lasted all up until like half the  season once we had already saw them one  time it was like hi bro you you you made  your decision like you got to stay over  there hey  let's beat them like now it's like bump  that i'm glad he over there let's deal  with this like